wedged into the middle of the great
novel The Hunchback of Notre Dame Victor
Hugo pauses the narrative to
philosophize on the ancient significance
of architecture from the beginning of
time he says cultures of the earth wrote
their thoughts with rock they made words
by superimposing stone upon stone the
Celtic dolma and chrome lick the
etruscan tomb ulis the hebrew gal gal
our words sometimes on a vast beach they
join these stone words and wrote a
sentence the traditions had given birth
to symbols under which they disappeared
like the trunk of a tree under its
foliage and the rock symbols had need to
expand into a structure in this way he
says architecture developed
concomitantly
with human thought reflected by the
great styles of the IRRI and by the
political and social revolutions Hindu
architecture gave way to Phoenician
Egyptian to Greek and Roman esque to
Gothic locked into the walls of these
temples palaces and churches a
civilization could launch what it knew
into the future confident that only the
greatest upheavals and natural disasters
might dislodge it from the earth but as
Notre Dame makes clear the gothic period
was the final page in this important
epoch of architecture the advent of the
printing press by Johannes Gutenberg
changed everything in printed books
ideas found an even more durable capsule
for transmission into posterity one that
costed far less to produce and one that
could be copied and sent across the
world the rise of the printing press
mirrors the decline of architecture as
the dominant aesthetic form on tumblr
last week and this is what got me
thinking about this topic the Cajun
cavalier asked me what role I thought
architecture plays in society besides
that of being a defense against the
elements and it seems to me that these
days architecture is governed like most
arts by pluralism there is no consensus
nor perhaps neither be as to a
representative style of the eight G eras
that came after the sunset of the
Renaissance were very reactionary to the
revivals of the past and sought to
create a new aesthetic following from
first the function
objectivity of modernism and then the
psychological subjectivity of post
modernist after just major urban
expansion that greatly emphasized the
function of structures over aesthetic or
function as aesthetic contemporary
architectural concerns seem largely to
deal with our society's next great
challenge sustainability or integration
with the environment and that's a
concern that has to be met with action
but it seems to me and I may be wrong
about this that there is a gross under
em Phasis of the power that architecture
plays on our consciousness and culture
the demarcation of physical space is the
spatial arrangement of inside and
outside what's communal what's private
in an urban environment have a massive
effect on the way we see ourselves in
our place in the society at large what
does it mean to live in a cramped studio
apartment in Manhattan what does it mean
to live in suburbia among cookie cutter
homes with perfect lawns the utilitarian
function of architecture is so obvious
that it almost disappears into the
background or rather it disappears as
the background and when we let it do so
when architecture becomes invisible to
us its influence for good or bad becomes
invisible as well in the inner city
where I live
demand is so high for livable spaces new
structures are built with such rapidity
that it's impossible to imagine any kind
of central architectural theory winning
out that's pluralism at work tolerant
but messy inclusive but alienating the
period after post-modernism has gone
mostly undefined I don't know if a
school of architecture will ever again
rise to cultural predominance just like
I don't know if we'll ever have a
classic literature with the same weight
as Shakespeare or F scott Fitzgerald but
if there ever was a time cajun cavalier
for a new architecture a new idea a new
choreography of space and humanity it
would be in the void of now
hey everybody thanks for watching as you
know a lot of time and research goes
into the making of these videos so I
want to thank the good people at
audible.com for sponsoring this one and
allowing me to do all that research and
spend all of that time if you haven't
heard about it
audible.com is awesome they're the
leading provider in audiobooks with over
150,000 titles fiction nonfiction
periodicals everything and if you go to
my URL audible.com slash Evan you'll get
a 30 day free trial and one free
audiobook that's a great opportunity to
learn more about architecture but in
this case I'm gonna recommend the
Hunchback of Notre Dame by Victor Hugo
it is an amazing book it's a classic and
it's by the way some way darker and
better than the Disney version and also
I went to the site and checked is read
by Jorge Quito who is one of the Masters
of audiobooks and I might just listen to
it again just to hear him do it they
have a free app so you can download it
put it on your phone which is what I
usually do listen to it on the subway or
I'll listen to it like in my bed before
I go to sleep for some reason that's
soothing to me um so go to audible.com
slash Evan get the hunchback of notre
dame on me I do want to mention that the
idea for this video came from the Cajun
Cavalier on tumblr last week I did a
video on video games and all week long
we were having conversations about it me
and all the people who watch this video
so I want to thank all of you
you've been commenting in the video
below you've been asking me anything on
tumblr where I can sort of expand on
things a little bit more so keep doing
that and I will see you next Friday